Tiens… Headshot !
Double headshot ! La brochette !
Matte le score de ouf Arthur !
Mes parents me harcèlent pour que j'appelle ma grand-mère...
Allez ! Fois quatre !
Putain !
Qu'est-ce qu'y a ?
Mon téléphone m'a brûlé !
Quoi ?
Attention ! Attention...
Y'a rien.
Merde !
Ça va ? T'arrêtes tes conneries un peu et tu me laisses jouer ?
Et ça, c'est des conneries ?
Je trouve rien sur internet, c'est bizarre ton truc.
Il y a forcément une explication.
Tu sais pas chercher en même temps...
Putain !
Moi ça va, heureusement moi ça va.
Fourchette.
C'est bon.
C'est bon !
Putain !
Oh, non...
Pour la console, je mets "oui mais avec brûlure"
Mets non alors.
Lunettes.
Banane...
- Banane c'est bon ?
- C'est bon banane.
Télécommande...
Putain !
Mais t'es con !
Le petit dinosaure ! Est-ce que tu peux jouer au dinosaure ?
Ça va ! On se marre !
Alors...
Merci.
Moi aussi je peux !
Alors... cigarette. Bon tu fumes pas...
Ah ! Nique sa...
J'ai compris. T'es allergique à la technologie !
Oh non...
Arthur, c'est quoi ces histoires ?
Non mais en fait je ne peux plus toucher d'ordinateur monsieur !
Si vous voulez un jour de congé, il suffit de le demander gentiment, pas la peine de faire le fou.
Non mais c'est sérieux, regardez.
Ça vous dérange pas de décrocher pour moi ?
Parce que moi ça me brûle.
Vous devez transférer les appels à facturation à la compta.
Oui, c'est ce que je fais depuis tout à l'heure.
Ça vous dérange pas de juste cliquer et glisser dans le mail ?
Juste là... Asseyez-vous.
"Ci-joint le dossier..."
"ER" pas "É" ! N'importe quoi...
Je reviens je vais me faire un petit café.
Et on va pas sur Facebook ! Parce que sinon...
On respire... et on relâche.
On respire ! On relâche.
Non franchement tout va bien. Simplement ce type d'allergie, j'ai jamais vu.
Jamais.
Du coup je vais guérir ?
Non. Je vais en parler à des collègues mais... je sais pas.
Putain !
Bah ouais c'est vrai...
En même temps c'est dommage parce que je viens de l'acheter, j'étais hyper content de pouvoir l'essayer.
- Non !
- Faites-moi plaisir.
- Ça brûle !
- Une petite...
- Pas sur moi !
-Ok.
Ils sont cons eux...
T'as quoi aux mains là ?
Non j'ai rien.
- Si t'as quelque chose.
- Non j'ai rien...
T'as fait quelque chose à tes cheveux ?
T'as remarqué ?
Hé Arthur ! Réflexe !
Putain !
Le mec est allergique à la technologie !
Attends, comment tu fais pour aller sur Facebook ?
Euh... j'y vais pas.
Et comment tu fais pour Snapchat alors ?
Je... Je peux plus y aller...
Le bad ! Et pour les sites porno ?
C'est contagieux ou pas ?
Désolé mais j'avais pas pensé à ça...
Oui bonjour Lionel, ici Stéphane en direct, écoutez je suis à seulement quelques mètres d'Arthur !
Arthur ! Ça va Arthur ? Je peux t'appeler Arthur?
Premier cas de technophobie au monde, allergie à la technologie.
Alors est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer comment ça se passer dans ton quotidien...
Non, je veux pas en parler !
Les textos, les emails tout ça...
Et pour les sites de cul, comment ça marche ?
Pour les sites de cul...
Non ! Non !
Nickel, c'est exactement ce qu'il me fallait... Putain !
Je comprends...
Juste un livre là bas, juste un...
Arthur. Vous ne voulez pas travailler pour des raisons qui vous regardent... OK.
Mais vous pourriez au moins faire l'effort de venir en réunion.
Il y avait un réunion c'est ça ?
On vous a prévenu par mail la semaine dernière !
Mais moi je ne peux plus voir mes mails monsieur.
Vous ne verrez plus votre salaire alors.
Yann ?
Arthur ! Ça va ? Ça fait longtemps qu'on s'est pas vu !
T'as toujours ton truc bizarre ?
Mon allergie, ouais.
Ça fait tellement plaisir de te voir !
Pareil.
Je vois plus personne, c'est fou, je me fais chier chez moi
j'en suis réduis à lire les résumés des films au dos des DVD...
Pareil... Mais t'étais pas là à l'anniversaire de Charlotte hier soir
C'était marrant, pourquoi t'es pas venu ?
J'étais pas au courant, vous avez fait un truc ?
...de quoi ? Mais t'étais dans l'évènement Facebook.
Mais je peux plus aller sur Facebook.
Fais pas genre, on t'as envoyé des textos.
Je peux plus aller sur mon téléphone Yann.
Excuse-moi, faut que j'y aille, tu m'appelles !
Ok Google, où est-ce que j'habite ?
Fais chier...
Putain, c'est où déjà...
Arthur ! Quelle surprise !
Je suis désolé d'avoir oublié ton anniversaire mamie.
Non t'inquiètes pas, t'étais occupé c'est normal.
Entre !
Ça me fait plaisir de te voir Arthur. C'est gentil d'être passé.
Mamie, j'ai quelques conseils à tes demander.
Comment tu fais pour vivre sans technologie ?
Comment ça ?
Sans technologie, sans ordinateur, sans GPS...
GPS?
C'est les cartes électroniques pour se repérer, t'as pas ça mamie ?
J'utilise des cartes pas-électroniques.
Ah ouais... Je suis con...
Oui.
J'ai pas de conseils à te donner pour ton... ta maladie là.
Mais j'ai peut-être quelques trucs pour toi.
Tout ça ?
Je m'en sers plus.
Ça t'ira peut-être.
Putain ! Oh oui !
Commissariat de police, bonjour.
Ouais ?
Yann ! Ça marche ! J'entends ta voix !
Vas-y dit un truc !
- Ça va ?
-“ Ça va ?”
J'entends ta voix, t'es pas dans la même pièce ! C'est un truc de fou !
Mec, il faut absolument qu'on se voit. Ce soit, j'organise une teuf.
C'est toi Arthur ?
Franchement, ce soir...
Oh putain !
C'est tellement stylé les vinyls !
Ça sent le vintage !
On fait une photo ! Smile !
Mec, j'ai pas été cool de pas prendre ta... ton truc...
...enfin ta maladie au sérieux.
Du coup voilà, je t'offre un petit cadeau pour m'excuser.
À priori, t'as pas besoin de le recharger souvent.
Et tu peux le démarrer comme ça.
Et après tu zoom comme ça.
C'est super bien fait !
Et c'est tactile du coup ?
Voilà ! Tout est tactile, tu changes de page comme ça.
C'est super bien fait.
Merci.
C'est pas xHamster mais ce que j'ai trouvé de mieux.
Ça fait longtemps.
C'est un de ces bordels là dedans, ça a bien besoin de rangement, franchement !
Arthur? Ah oui donc c'est vrai que tu ranges tout.
T'aurais pas trouvé le contrat de notre fournisseur chinois par hasard ?
- Oh c'est génial !
- Je l'ai trouvé ce matin !
Tu me sauves la vie, merci !
…. Monsieur Terrier...
Oui vous cherchez un truc ?
Arthur, nous avons beaucoup entendu parler de vous ces dernières semaines.
Vous êtes officiellement le premier cas de technophobie.
Oui c'est bien ça.
Vous pouvez nous expliquer ce que c'est ?
Je suis allergique à la technologie.
Donc je ne peux plus toucher d'ordinateur, de tablette, de smartphone, plus rien.
Ah bah non !
Tous les jeunes qui nous regardent doivent penser que c'est un véritable cauchemar !
Ils ont bien raison, on peut dire ça.
Oui les filles, j'ai gagné !
Non, fais voir tes cartes !
J'ai pas triché !
Du coup vous n'allez pas craquer pour le prochain iPhone ?
Non, de ce côté là au moins je fais des économies.
Non j'en veux pas ! C'est un cadeau !
On a tous envie de savoir
Comment vit-on avec la technophobie ?
Comment on vit avec la technophobie ?
Bah non, pas encore !
On s'y fait.